hello everyone as you know from my
previous videos Talon is Medina played
four games altogether four official
games you already seen two games on my
channel I will put a link to those games
in the description below in the first
video I said something more about
Rasheed is Medina and his and his
acquaintance with tal and their mutual
relationship and and things like that so
I don't wanna talk about it more in this
video but I do want to tell you that of
those four games that they play that
consider this one to be the most
beautiful because when Talon is Medina
of meat over the board it doesn't matter
if it's the opening the middle game or
the end game there is always magic on
the board as you will see in this game
so the game was played in 1959 it was
played in Moscow and animation Medina as
in all four games has the white pieces
so let's see the game Rasheed opens with
e 4 and C 5 the Sicilian defense by Tao
Knight to f3 d6 d4 seek after Sundy for
knife captures on d4 and a 6 we have the
con variation Knight to c3 Queen to c7
and Bishop to d3 we have Knight to c6
and Rasheed plays Bishop to e3 now
transposing into the boss typical
variation of the time on oath Knight to
f6 by tau our castles and here tall has
a couple of options he can simply go
there should be seven castles and
continue the game maybe it would be five
the b5 there should be seven but tau
goes for Knight to e5 and it seems like
I will move at least you know you
already played with that piece and the
light square bishop doesn't seem like
such a powerful piece to capture but ok
he played nine three five and we have h3
not allowing any Knight to g4 ideas b5
by tau preparing bishop to be 7 and F
for now Knight the c-4 now I'm going for
the dark square Bishop and this is a
more powerful Bishop in this variation
so Bishop captures on c4 Rashid parts
with the bishop pair Queen captures on
c4 and here Talia has some ideas of
pushing b4 and I move like e5 will be
met with before
so our she plays Queen to the
he over here for the trade of Queens d5
by Tao and we have a capture son b5 now
tall exchanges Queens queen capture son
b3c capture son b3 and b4 and already
you can see that towel or towel has the
upper hand
this night has to move these pawns are
doubled the towel is ready to capture
this point when the c3 Knight moves so
Knight to e4 and we have Knight
characters on d5 we have Bishop to d2
getting the better part of the way as
the knight was attacking it and the here
towel played a5 and there really wasn't
it wasn't necessary and he played a 5 to
give the b4 pawn for the protection and
is preparing a bishop day 6 to go for
this week d3 pawn but there is time for
this the d3 pawn isn't going anywhere
I move like g6 Bishop to g7 would have
been better to control this strong
diagonal but ok he played a 5 and this
is met with rook to c1
Bishop to a6 going for the d3 pawn and
here rush it plays rook F 2 e1 showing
tile that the d3 pawn wasn't really that
worth it if tal were to capture this
pawn with bishop character son b3 f5 is
coming and now after Bishop captures
rook captures these exponents attacked
three times you don't really have a way
of stopping this even if you play Knight
to f6 to kick the rook rook to e2 and
now rub the DA to attack the knight
Knight is coming to b5 again you have a
double attack on the e6 pawn also night
the c7 check is coming with a triple
attack on the e6 pawn so you cannot grab
this pawn in any way and the d3 pawn is
a much less important than the strong e6
pawn
so after rook after you want a low I
decided to go for g6 preparing to
develop the bishop but now comes the
magic hero ah she plays f5 and it's a
very interesting idea why would you play
a 5 in this position well ok obviously
if you play he captures on f5 this is
terrible since Knight captured Knight to
f6 check King to d8 is only move and now
rook to e8 this is checkmate so this is
pretty obvious you're not gonna capture
with the e pawn
but if you capture with the Jeep on this
is actually much better for towel for
example Knight to c5 you simply capture
rook captures you can freely castle and
okay her she does have this Knight
captures on a5 move but now comes the
Bishop capture son b3 and it's a much
better position for tile he's up up upon
and you know this is this is very much
playable but after f5 towel got the idea
that he would like to play Bishop to g7
with the idea of developing the bishop
puts the tempo on the knight on d4 and
he thought okay after the knight moves I
will only then play G captures on f5 but
this is were rashida tricked him here
Rasheed played f6 and in Tahoe I'm
pretty sure tile didn't consider this
move as its it's not a good move but
Rasheed plays it so he's given up a pawn
talk after zat Knight captures on f6
here comes Knight to d6 would check by
rashid king to e7 and now comes the the
amazing finish Medina of Knight captures
on f7 so what do you do here I mean the
rook is attacked you you obviously have
to capture it there's a double attack on
d6 pawn so King captures on f7 and now
rook to c7 check so what do you do here
King to g8 this is actually the only
good move
Knight captures on e6 and although
Rasheed sacrificed a piece he's already
threatening rook captures on g7
checkmate so nice to e8 this is the only
good move for black and tall plays it
he's defending the g7 pawn the g7 bishop
and now comes rock to d7 as the knight
was attacking the rook Bishop to f6 and
already this is what happens when you
play against Nativity knows this is a
perfectly fine position for black and
black has many ways to continue this
game for example you can play h6
to make some room for the king you can
also play h5 a more direct way would be
to play for example Bishop to b5 you
kick the rook from the seventh rank only
then you play h6 or h5 does
really matter but after this rook to d7
move Tao played Bishop to f6 probably I
I don't really know why it's very hard
to imagine why it all played Bishop to
f6 there probably is a reason to it if
any of you can find a good reason for
this move what's the idea behind Bishop
f6 feel free to share in the comments
but this loses instantly it was just
only one move and rush it finds this
move it's up to f1 and now tallies in
deep trouble the immediate threat of
course is if you if you move the bishop
anywhere for example I don't know you
play something like I don't even know
what I wanted to do with this Bishop
let's say you capture the pawn I get
rock to f8 checkmate
but even if you don't there's really
nothing you can play if you play Bishop
b5 to take the route now then comes rook
captures on f6
and now there is no defense it's either
rook to g7 checkmate if for example if
you capture this rook it's this rope to
g7 checkmate
and if you capture this rook then it's
this rook to f8 checkmate so there is no
defense it's making one regardless of
what black plays so after rocker f1 it's
it's it's game over basically Knight to
g7 was played by tau but now comes rope
captures on f6 knowledge Medina got his
piece back he's up upon but none of that
really matters as his position is so
active tasking isn't g8 the rook the
rook is on h8 drew can never enter the
game so Knight captures on e6 this was
the only move for tall rock characters
on e6 and those white rooks are
extremely active it's very hard to play
this Bishop to b5 now comes rock to c7
still not allowing the King to enter the
game h5 this had to be played you have
to give up the g6 pawn
- maybe maybe be able to activate your
rook on h8 but rook to g6 check King f8
and now Bishop to h6 check King to e8
and rook to e6 check came to d8 my towel
and now rook to c5 or the temple
on the bishop here King to be seven
attacking the rook now rook comes the b6
now the bishop is attacked twice Bishop
captures and III tell grabs upon but
doesn't really matter much here in this
position Bishop to a forest played
threatening rocks e7 rook d6 depends on
what black plays actually rook H to f8
Talman and just to activate the h8 rook
but it's it's too late rook to D success
played King to e7 now rub the c7 check
King t8 and here we have rook Bishop to
g5 the threat of course is rook to e7
and this comes with checkmate so rook to
f1 check King to h2 and now Bishop to be
one getting all the pieces out of some
nasty discoveries Rasheed might have and
there are actually a lot of winning
moves here
rook to e6 is winning rook to e7 check
is winning but sorry but there is one
move that finishes the game instantly
and Rasheed of course finds it it's rook
to h6 and in this position Michael Tao
resigns the game so what's the idea the
idea is of course rope to h8 checkmate
there is no way to stop this and if we
try rock to f8 to prevent this idea then
simply rook to e6 is checkmate because
now you've blocked f8 the only escape
square for the King so yeah this is the
third game I've shown you the third
official game between michal thailand
Rishikesh medina so so so far I had the
result is a three to zero for Rashida
Schmidt you know if there is only one
more game left I will eventually show
this game as well and yeah that's it I
hope you enjoyed this game I would like
to thank Fredrik marks for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and what what
do you guys think is that is it finally
time that feed a Awards Rashid Nash
Medina with the honorary Grandmaster
title but they're probably never gonna
do it but so you know as I always say
it's furnished medina it's better to be
a legend who never became a grandmaster
then for a lot of players to be
grandmasters who never became legends so
yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here like I said there
will be a link in the description below
to both of the previous games tall
versus Latino be sure to check those out
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon